When I first got to Google.
I was trying to wrap up
on all things sysadmin.
It was overwhelming.
There were so many tools to learn so
many ways of doing the same thing.
Luckily, I got to sit next to
Kelsey on a two hour bus ride.
I started asking him questions I said,
Kelsey.
I'm having information overload
there are so many tools out there.
What should I learn, what's the fastest
way for me to become productive?
And he said there's only one rule
way to manage applications and
that's Kubernetes.
And he spent the next two
hours showing me Kubernetes.
After that I wasn't so
overwhelmed anymore.
Kubernetes made sense to me because it
looked at containers at a higher level.
It was an abstraction that made sense.